hello everyone and welcome to round
three of the 2018 candidates tournament
although I'm sure after we see the game
you will think I'm covering again from
the 1959 candidates tournament as this
game is really insane
I mean facing Vladimir Kramnik in Berlin
while he plays the Berlin if that's not
a bad omen I don't know what is and okay
we have 11 already on with the white
pieces and Kramnik with the black pieces
and so far this is round 3
onion is at one point out of - he drew
both of his games and kramnik won one
game and drew one game so one and a half
point out of two and for those of you
who maybe don't know this kramnik teamed
up with onigiri so he took on each
curious his second to help him out with
his preparations for the game and this
tournament as the two of them definitely
do have a similar style and let's see
what they came up with so ironin opens
with E for which is of course
immediately interesting Aragon is not an
e4 player but he doesn't want to go d4
against Vladimir Kramnik as his Queens
gambit declined is fairly famous but on
the other hand if you play E 4 against
pramik you know you're gonna face the
Berlin as he did take down world
champion Garry Kasparov with his Berlin
defence without Kasparov winning a
single game so e 592 f3 knight c6 and
Bishop to b5 Duru Lopes and here kramnik
goes for his signature move Knight to f6
and we entered the Berlin defence d3
Bishop to c5 Bishop captures the D
captures on c6 and here in this position
aragon castles and castling it's not
like this is a mistake but you give
black too many options here better was
maybe a waiting move like h3 but now
Cromley decides to go for a different
line he goes for Queen to e7 h3 and now
he plays rook to GA so chronic shows
that he has no intentions of castling
and while 11 aragon castles so early
chronic is ready to push his G pawn king
to h1 and now Knight to h5 and if you if
you look at this position now black
isn't
here but look at White's development
here he only has this night and have
three developed while Kramnik has the
Bishop on c5 the night is nicely placed
on h5 ready to push g5 the queen is
active on e7 the bishop is ready to jump
into the game the light square bishop so
although Kramnik isn't better here it's
it's easier to play this position with
black here my c3 was played preparing to
push d4 Cromley goes for g5 and here you
really have to be careful probably the
best move for white is d4 simply
countering this bishop and offering an
exchange in the center after he capture
C captures bishop moves mountain Knight
2 h2 simply controlling the g4 square
but after Knight to f6 Blackwell who g4
nevertheless but still it's better than
what onion went for in the game after
this g5 moved by Kramnik RN and played
and Knight captures on e5 and seems like
seems like a decent move now with black
captures are then will capture the night
on h5 also d4 will definitely be an idea
since there's no more a pawn but chronic
doesn't capture the night here chronic
plays g4 and it's probably this move
that are in young missed as if he saw
this I doubt he would ever capture on e5
here d4 was played Bishop to d6 and
mouth g3 of course preparing h4 you
still can't capture a GTR is nh3 because
your knight is hanging on h5 but chronic
plays Bishop captures on e5 d captures
on e5 and now Queen captures on e5 Queen
to d4 offering an exchange of created
Queens and in the live coverage during
the live coverage everyone thought that
premier could accepted the Queen trade
and go for a superior ending here but
chronic actually declines the trade of
Queens he plays Queen to e7 and he wants
to keep going at it he wants to attack
H for closing the position on the Kings
side and now c5 Queen to c4 we have
Bishop to e6 forcing the Queen even
further back Queen to b5 checked at c6
and this was the critical moment of the
game this was Oregon's last chance the
the Queen over to d3 to help out with
the defense but here Aragon played Queen
to a4 and now it's already made chronic
and from this moment this is move this
is move 18 from this moment on chronic
played the best possible move in every
position and it's it's truly an amazing
game you're welcome to try and find the
move kramnik played here and it's the
only move that allows black to keep his
advantage so feel free to pause the
video and find promix move so I will
give it a couple of seconds as always
for those of you who were able to find
chronic smooth congratulations you are
an excellent player and for those who if
you just want to enjoy the show here
chronic played f5 and if you found that
five you probably found the following
variation here it captures on f5 simply
isn't possible because of night captures
on g3 would check now if you move the
King King G to simply Knight captures an
x5 and white King side is shattered the
knight to the Queen are aligned on h4
and if you don't if you play something
like capturing the knight of them comes
the Bishop to b5 check and now it's all
over King do you want Queen to e2
threatening checkmate on g2 and there's
no way to stop this you can block with
the rook about not simply Queen to e1
check the King moves Queen to h1 this is
checkmate and if you don't move the King
if you try and block with the rope to f1
you get to Queen to g3 and this is
checkmate immediately so after this f5
move it's a move origin missed he
probably could have resigned immediately
but these are the candidates you don't
want to resign and move 18 what the hell
you are having the white pieces after
all and you're I don't I don't know if
he's still 2800 but somewhere around
2800 so he he tried to complicate things
a bit he played Bishop to g5 but Kramnik
almost immediately shattered this with
rook captures on g5 h captors on g5 and
now f4 Queen captures and jihad was also
possible but f4 is the most precise move
Queen to d1 arena now tries to bring the
Queen back over to the defense and here
we have rook to d8 by R and F captors
and g3 of
good move but chronic first takes this
opportunity to introduce another
attacker into the game so why not as it
does come for free
Queen to see one and now F captures ng3
Queen Catherine G fog was also possible
F captors and g3 is better
night two eight three rock the d3 again
a best move here by Vladimir Kramnik
and now rook to d1 our enemies trying
anything although and any move he makes
is basically a losing move but he he he
he has to try something and here there
are a lot of winning moves again
you're free to pause this position as
well and I tried to find I don't know
how to put it try to find the most
brilliant move like if this was played
in 1959 and chronic played what he
played in this game I have no doubts
that he would win the brilliancy prize
for this game so feel free to pause it
and if you found the rook to a3 that's
perfectly fine that's winning if you
found rookie out for Sandy one perfectly
fine that's also winning but the move
chronic played wins on the spot and he
played Bishop to d5 so if you look at
this game and all of the moves gromek
played like he played it perfectly I
don't know if it's something he cooked
up himself is it his own preparation
with URI or is it simply brilliance over
the board regardless it's it's an
amazing game so here you obviously can't
capture the bishop on d5 if you play
ECAP torse on d5 then you get Queen to
e4 check King to g1 then comes captures
on f2 King to f1 9 IG 3 check King has
the captain out now Queen to f3 check
King moves 90 e to check King to h2 and
now Queen to h3
this is a forced checkmate so we don't
really have the option of capturing on
d5 here in this position our onion
played f3 and here G captures on f3 was
played and now he captures on d5 and
although I mean Aragon is still
completely lost it's it's a shame he
didn't allow this brilliant end of the
game after rook captures on d3 after
rook captures on d3
Kramnik would have the
plain Queen captures on e4 and now after
rook to e3 it seems like our union is
about to win chronics queen but here
comes f2
the king is in check there is no move
here to be played you would have to
capture the Queen and then Bishop
captures on e4 and this is checkmate as
the DF 2 ng3 born our completely gutting
of the white king so unfortunately the
game did it end like this after G
captures on f3 are exempt late he
captures on d5 here chronic again goes
for the most precise move Queen to e2
threatening checkmate on either h2 or g2
rook to e1 was played again it seems
like onion is winning chronics queen but
here comes G to check and after this G
to check Aragon resigned in this
position as it's a force checkmate in
four moves whatever white place if you
go King to g1 then simply have to check
King has the capture and then f1 bring
your Queen into the game it's a double
check rather it's checkmate as the all
of the pieces are working together
nicely here on the other hand after G to
check in to the O king to H to first
black will give up one point and then
after King captures it's the same as in
the previous variation after check King
moves and now rotation 3 check King G to
end f1 this is checkmate so yeah a
beautiful game after rook e1 it's a
shame he didn't and would that Queen
sacrifice are an undecided T he doesn't
want to give a lot more chronic
displeasure but an amazing game
nevertheless if you look at this
position orokin d3 Queen on e2 pawn on
f3 pawn on g2 and the knight and h5 and
it's only move
27 I mean it's it's a it's a darn shame
that there's no brilliancy prize to be
awarded at the 2018 candidates
tournament as a vitamin chronic would
definitely earn one here as there were
no severe mistakes I mean that Queen to
a4 instead of Queen to d3 was a severe
mistake but you know you have to find
that five and pramukh plated to pretty
quickly so again I don't know if it was
a home preparation or over the board
Berlin seed
either way what a game to be played in
around
of the 2018 candidates tournament so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it all the other games are still
going on I think one game was drawn but
I will check out if there will be some
other interesting games the cover
although till her till the end of the
tournament it will be very hard for any
game to surpass this game but yeah it's
a long tournament we'll just have to see
so thank you all for watching as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here yeah thank you all and I will see
you soon